kanye west giving a very interesting
interview on his run for president
yeah you have another choice in the race
the rapper breaking with president trump
saying he's taking his red hat
off but that doesn't mean he has any
love for joe biden and the democrats
saying quote
a lot of times just like political
parties they feel all blacks have to be
democrat
this man joe biden said if you don't
vote for me
then you are not black well act like we
didn't hear that
we act like we didn't hear that man say
that that man said that
he sure did juan williams and it didn't
sit well with a lot of voters
what do you have to say about that
well obviously didn't bother 9 out of 10
black voters who
are still voting for biden but you know
you can't discount these popular culture
figures
kennedy uh after president trump's
victory i think the door is open now i
must say there are rules
and kanye i think dana pointed this out
last time we discussed it
he's missed filing deadlines in like
five states so
that puts him at a tremendous electoral
college disadvantage
if he's actually going to go out there
and run and i think i read this
interview his thing against vaccinations
calling it you know beastly and the like
i mean what happened polio has he
forgotten i mean i think that's a real
negative now he does say in the
interview
that the government should be run like
wakanda
uh well might be good i don't know might
be better than the one we
have yeah and
but you know i have to say i like that
he's getting in there mixing things up
and talking about things and ways that
no one else is because
the two-party system gets so stale jesse
he also
said that joe biden is not special
is joe biden special jesse
uh yeah no that's so true he's not
special i just can't believe juan's
actually saying that
kanye west has missed some filing
deadlines like okay where are we right
now
um i don't think he's going to make
those deadlines juan
but i will tell you this i think if
you're a democrat and you feel
disenfranchised
that you should write in kanye west's
name on the ballot this november if you
live in philadelphia
milwaukee or detroit and you're feeling
kanye you should write
his name in because hey kanye's kanye
and maybe he didn't take the red hat off
maybe just threw it in the closet for a
second but
i'm i'm feeling pretty good about a
kanye write-in situation
or greg maybe he's working with
president trump
maybe maybe they're in cahoots he could
be and and
the president has advised him to get
into the race to siphon off
some critical votes from joe biden
he he could decide the election if he
chooses to
um he the most important thing he said
in the interview is that he doesn't mind
if he takes black votes from the
democrats which then helps trump
because he said because he said i think
i'm quoting him that the black saying
that the black vote is democratic
is a form of racism and white supremacy
and this goes back to what i said
yesterday
he's creating a voting bloc independent
of parties
to get both sides to vie for that block
remember the democrats don't have to buy
they don't think they have to buy for
blacks
republicans try to buy every single
election and they don't do that well
he he has to run as a democrat in order
to get the democrats
to pay attention to him or they're going
to lose
i don't know dana how do you see this
race shaping up with the uh
my 11 year old you know her she asked me
the other day she's like
mom you're voting for kanye so i don't
know what to do right now
look you know celebrity um and fame
um gives you an opportunity to be able
to have a platform of which he does
i will say in juan's defense i'm the one
who brought up that he had missed the
filing deadlines and that is just a fact
that he
that he has the write-in is certainly a
possibility
i do question the judgment of giving
this first interview to forbes
obviously that interview should have
gone to the daily briefing and will be
happy to have it many times yes
well you know what tomorrow we'll see
what happens because those follow-ups
they're coming fast and furious like the
fastest seven